[Music]
there's really only one renewable energy
source that can power the whole world
right now today and that solar energy
there's more than enough solar energy
hitting the earth to power the earth
many times over we're all familiar with
the story of solar technology limitless
potential somewhat disappointing results
one of the big hurdles is where to put
it in the places where we most need
power there isn't a lot of space for big
heavy opaque panels of course if you
could make solar cells thin light and
transparent you could put them almost
anywhere
[Music]
so this is actually a solar panel that
you're probably familiar with been
around for decades and what this does is
it absorbs the light that hits the
surface and it converts that light into
electricity so here's an example of a
transparent version so this is a
transparent solar cell there you may
yeah okay we're commercializing what we
call a transparent solar cell it's
really just an invisible film that you
can put on any surface you can go on a
mobile device display can go on a
building window and it can generate
energy on those surfaces our vision was
really that we want to integrate solar
technology into the products and
surfaces we interact with every day the
idea of transparency kind of has risen
to the top is something that seems to
add a lot of value for a wide range of
applications
[Music]
in the past people tried to make solar
cells transparent by shrinking down the
size of the components but that only
gets you so far
ubiquitous figured out that the key to a
truly transparent solar cell isn't the
size of the parts you use but the kind
of light you're trying to absorb we've
designed photoactive materials that let
visible light pass through but can
selectively harvest the parts of the
solar spectrum that we can't see with
our eye namely the ultraviolet and the
near fred parts of the solar spectrum
and so we can have a very transparent
solar cell you're not capturing the
visible light presumably that is
affecting the efficiency of the panel to
some degree yeah if you look at a
traditional solar cell it absorbs light
in all parts of the spectrum of the
light that hits the surface 33% of that
light is converted into electricity with
a transparent cell you cut out the
visible part of the spectrum but you can
still achieve up to 22% with our pilot
production facility we expect to be able
to reach around 10% power efficiency
which is a drop but then I suppose there
are advantages to having things that you
can see through as opposed to things
that you cannot absolutely now you have
a lot more surface area that you can
apply solar technologies to the first
place ubiquitous wants to put its solar
cells is on the displays of mobile
devices which could mean the smartphone
of the near future never runs out of
batteries but the real potential of a
technology like this becomes clear when
you start to think big like skyscraper
big
[Music]
currently there's a huge amount of
surface area on the vertical space of
buildings that's unused for energy
harvesting utilizing transparent solar
cells to convert those windows into
solar panels as a way to utilize that
surface area for energy generation so
now you're not just constrained to these
types of devices on the roof you can
actually use the vertical area of the
buildings as well we see this as really
being deployed everywhere generating
power in the background without you even
knowing that it's there this won't be
the only solution that we need but we
see it as being a very important
technology to make a more sustainable
society
[Music]